hello everyone and welcome to the next
big classical event after the world
Chase Championship it is the super bet
chess classic classical Tournament being
played in the Grand Hotel in Bucharest
in Romania these are the gentlemen that
will be participating in this uh great
event from left to right you have the
the the locals uh Bogdan Daniel
the newly crowned world champion then
the world's Championship Challenger
alireza firuja is making his return back
from Fashion uh Anish giri Fabiano
caruana there's Wesley so Maxima
Sherlock and of course uh Yang shisht of
Duda and if you guys are wondering uh
how ding's first classical game as a
World Series champion went uh it was a
draw against Maxim vashiella Graf so
we'll see what happens in today's round
as uh well uh he will also get to play
Yanni ponies once again after the water
championship match so I'm sure everyone
is very eager to see that uh and um uh
Rapport who was dings second for the
world's championship match actually
faced the any polish and they drew their
game so it was a very nice one I decided
to show this one it's really a wild one
and also here is a nice photo of garika
spark he managed to snatch a photo with
the newly crowned world champion Dean
liren so let's enjoy that for a second
and now let's dive uh into the game so
like I said this is the first event of
the 2023 rant Chester uh 350 000 is the
is the total price uh first place we'll
get to 100 000 and as you can as you've
seen uh it's a it's a pretty pretty
strong field and missing only the at the
former world champion Magnus Carlsen so
let's uh see how it uh went uh here
alireza has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 we have E5 by Wesley
Knight to F3 Knights the C6 and now
Bishop the C4 with Bishop to C5 the
Italian game is on the board The Joker
piano now uh and alireza goes for Ponte
D3 uh the Joker pianissimo variation we
have V6 uh C3 and now Bishop B6 this is
a very rare continuation going Bishop to
B6 right away usually players will just
continue with Knight to F6 or H6 but
okay obviously has a very particular
idea in mind uh castles we have H6 and
now Knight beta D2 and already we are
pretty much in completely unexplored
territory there are a few games that
reach this position uh where Queen to F6
was played also Knight gt7 is a known
move uh but Wesley plays Knight to F6
and it is now already as of move 7 that
we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how it continues with Bishop
to B3 uh we have Pawn to A5 of course
preparing Pawn to A4 and now just Rook
to E1 now you want to have your E4 Pawn
sufficiently defended if at some point
you wanna execute D4 and of course this
Knight you know is coming to C4 so here
castles with Ponte H3 all very standard
moves uh Bishop to A6 And alireza Trades
Bishop captures F characters Wesley
doubles his pawns here but it's uh not
really an issue uh the the the the these
structures are very well known and you
know that you can make use of all of
these squares that you control here so
Knight to C4 now attacking the bishop
also putting pressure on the E5 Pawn
this also prevents uh uh Black from
executing D5 because the E5 Pawn would
hang so just Bishop back to A7 and now
Bishop to E3 offering a trade of dark
Square Bishops with Bishop captures on
E3 Rook captures you could also that are
F captures you could consider Knight
captures but alireza doesn't want to uh
do anything drastic and also maybe you
can get some attacking chances here if
you don't like moves maybe The Rook can
come to G3 uh who knows uh so Ponte A4
in the future you might also be looking
at a move like A3 to mess up oh there is
a spawn structure here uh and uh oh it
is uh uh has to decide what to play does
he push D4 right away or can he somehow
improve his position before they are
going for for this D4 move you could try
with something like Rook to C1 but then
B5 comes in already it's maybe black
who's dictating the tone of the battle
let's say Rook to B8 and now you will
get that D4 moving but your knight is no
longer on C4 and now uh black and also
play something like D5 then with CD
captures and E5 Knight captures on e4 C4
very important as the E4 Pawn a E4
Knight would be hanging if you you
capture with the epon so B captures and
C for Knight captures and now let's say
Knight E7 and the game continues with
black having some uh potential c5d for
ideas in the future so that's why aledez
I went for default right away E Capture
Sunday 4C captures and now just spawn to
D5 now it's possible as D5 Pawn is no
longer hanging so e captures on D5 uh we
have e counters on D5 and Knight back to
D2 uh Queen to D6 now
uh and uh here Ponte A3 uh very nicely
done stopping that uh Knight the B4 idea
uh but also uh also uh uh leaving some
holes here because now if the Knight
comes to A5 it then comes the B3 then to
C4 could also be very very uh hard to
deal with so Wesley first goes for
Bishop to have a queen to F4 he puts
pressure on the D4 uh Pawn uh prevents
uh developing moves so again uh the only
way to defend the pawn is to move the
knights the B1 which is what alveza does
uh Knights the E4 and now just Knights
the C3 we have Knight captures and C3
and now alireza doesn't capture with the
B Pawn if you capture with the B Pawn
then Knight A5 is very strong you can't
play Queen captures because Knight C4
will expose the the queen and also
attack The Rook on E3 so you're just
waiting for Knight to B3 or Knight to C4
which will be uh those will be some
excellent scores for black so that's why
Rook captures and C3 this also prevents
the knight from moving because the C7
Pawn would hang and Wesley goes back
Queen to decent it's sort of a waiting
move but also in some tricky lines it
prevents a move like Rook to C5 because
then you might even capture and D4 as
The Rook will be undefended not while
the queen is on D1 obviously but uh uh
you know you you still have to struggle
to find someone so Rook uh Rook the C1
and now Rook the F7 not nicely defending
the F the C7 Pawn we have Rook one to C2
uh adding more support to the second
Rank and now Rook the F4 alireza shifts
his attention to the D4 Pawn Rook to E3
now uh alireza wants to double up on the
E file we have Queen to F6 and now Rook
to D3 adding another Defender here as um
Wesley's putting pressure on that D4
Pawn Rook to E8 and now Rook the C5
putting pressure on the D5 pawn queen to
D6 Rook back to C3 and now Rook F the E4
now this is how uh with some new ring
Wesley manages to double up Rooks on the
E file uh G3 uh we have Rook to E2 and
now Rook the D2 Wesley trades characters
captures and now Queen to G6
um uh pretty much looking for that B1
square and if Queen to V1 check lands uh
could be very annoying but uh uh Alvarez
even invites it Wesley does play Queen
to B1 and now Rook to C1 just chasing
the queen away because you can't really
do all that much the Knight can't move
you allow Rook to E1 so the queen has to
be kicked a rook to C1 we have Queen
back to F5 Rook to C3 and we have a
repetition Queen to B1 but now H4
alvareza declines the repetition he
wants to play on Rook D7 now Rook the C1
kicks the queen back Queen F5 and now
Queen to D1 and this is uh basically the
the star move of the game here it's uh
kind of equal you could just uh repeat
moves Rook D1 Rook to C1 and nothing is
really happening by playing Queen to D1
uh you are saying uh okay I'm gonna win
the A4 Pawn there is no way Wesley can
defend da for Pawn because of B5 the
Knight on C6 hangs but it also gives up
the crucial G5 Square the control of the
of the crucial G5 square and that's
exactly what Wesley has to do in order
uh to try and make something of this
game so he plays a pawn to G5 now let's
see what alireza had in mind here age
captures H captures and now Queen back
to D2 just threatening to pick up on G5
uh Pawn to G4 now Knight H4 attacking
the queen and queen the E4 with check
with King to H do and now Queen captures
on D4 so while it is a
is now down upon but he has Queen to G5
check Rook to G7 and now Queen to F5 can
he do something with this can he do some
some checks can he maybe bring the the
Knight to F5 put some pressure on the
queen and the Rook uh well Rook to F7
Queen to G5 and now King the f8 now it's
Wesley uh who declines the repetition
here uh and now the problem is if you
continue the attack let's say Knight to
G6 you can go King eight and even if
Rook D1 check you play King to D7
there's no way to continue the attack
you would love to play Knights to E5 uh
it's just that the knight from C6 uh
just uh controls that square uh so
there's no way to do it even if you
prepare it with something like Rook to
C1 hoping to uh capture uh the the F2
Pawn is saying you're gonna get the
checkmated so there's just no time so
instead King the H1 now uh queen or Rook
captures on F2 will not come with check
but Wesley doesn't rush it he plays
Queen T for check first king to G1 and
now King 38 he just wants to bring his
King to safety and enjoy his position
being up a pawn uh we have Queen to D2
now comes Rook to E7 we have Rook to D1
attacking the pawn but now Pawn to D4
and here with this move Wesley says my
D4 Pawn is defended by the Knight there
is no counter play here you're just down
a pawn and you will have to suffer for
the rest of the game so Queen to G5 uh
we have Knight the E5 now going for that
F3 square and queen back to D2 the
Knight is guarding the F3 Square so you
don't have to worry all that much but
you you still have to worry
uh Pawn to D3 just nicely defending that
past Pawn uh Queen to F4 and here Wesley
plays Queen captures on F4 which is a
mistake uh here you you could actually
win quite easily with Queen to E2 uh
point is that now The Rook is hanging
and you have to deal with that you're
probably gonna move the Rook or play
Queen to D2 and it doesn't really matter
what you do because now there's a rook
to H7 this is the the other star move of
the game although in a position that
never occurred and now you don't really
have a rook capture as an H4 is coming
followed by Knight to F3 check and even
if you trade Queens it doesn't matter
the captures attacks the Knight and once
the uh rugos D1 you still play Knight F3
check now uh you either lose the Rook or
you trade here and there's no playing
this it's a game over so a very weird
for for Westland to go for this queen
captures on F4 move but okay he had uh
he had an idea G captures an F4 Knight
to C4 and now Rook captures on D3 Knight
captures on B2 and The Rook the C3 so it
does seem like he gave Alvarez some
counter play here uh Rook to D7 uh we
have King to G2 and now Knights the D3
uh so still okay you're up upon alireza
will still have to fight very hard for a
draw King the G3 defends the F4 Pawn uh
Pawn to C5 now and now one spawn to C5
was played you know what's coming you
once you see this move you know what's
coming up until this point you you felt
that you probably had some drawing
chances but now you can see B5 B4 on the
board and well it either works or it
doesn't there's nothing you can do here
so King captures on G4 Ponta B5 uh
Knight to F5 battle it is a king to F7
now we have King to G5 and now Rook to
D5 uh not allowing the knights to move
we have Rook the C2 and now Knights the
E1 attacking the rook and alireza played
Rook to C3 here uh Rook to E2 seems like
a move you want to play attacking the
Knight and going for Rook to E7 uh the
problem is it still doesn't work even
this um uh would fail uh for example
Knight to F3 check King G4 and now Rook
captures an F5 that's the problem now if
you uh capture The Rook then Knight the
D4 check picks up the rook and if you
capture the Knight then B4 comes and
okay now what you want to do is if
rookie four you're just gonna play B3
for cat person A4 uh you're hoping to
get this check in and then Rook B7 kind
of defends the the the pawn uh attacks
the pawn and prevents it from promoting
but now King G6 the only winning move uh
Rook to A7 now we're gonna play C4 and
now those pawns are too strong Rook the
B7 Rook to C5 you will now Advance the
pawn uh King to E2 C3 King to D1 you
will play C2 with checking the C2 and
now Rook C3 you defend the pawn also
you're threatening Rook D3 uh followed
by Rook to D1 check and that's it
there's no no surviving this so that's
why even with top engine play uh you
you'd have a very hard time saving this
so it is a played a different line he
played Rook to C3 now comes Knight to D3
and now Rook back to C2 defending the
pawn here but now Pawn to B4 Wesley
waited as long as possible uh to execute
this B4 move but now it comes just at
the right moment a captures on B4 C
captures now Rook the C7 with check King
to E8 and now King the F6 the sneakiest
of moves by alireza because now uh if
Wesley uh just continues pushing pawns
as many of us would uh Knight G7 check
King goes here Knights the E6 checking
goes here and now Rook D7 uh Checkmate
uh you you don't want to mess up your
advantage like this so of course Wesley
spots this he plays King 38 now comes
Rook to A7 outputs pressure on the pawn
but just Pawn to B3 Wesley shows that if
you capture the pawn pawn B2 and the B4
and A1 squares are covered you cannot
take that you cannot stop that pawn from
promoting so Knight the E3 was played
but now Rook the D6 with check King to
F5 and pawn to B2 we have rooked the B7
stopping the pawn just rooked the D4 now
uh the the V2 one is defended you're
gonna capture the F4 Pawn you're going
to capture the F2 Pawn so the principle
of many weaknesses if you will Knights
the C2 and now Rook captures an F4 with
checking to G5 and Rook captures an F2
attacks the Knight alireza played Knight
the A3 but here just Rook to F1 and he
was in this position on move 72 that
alireza firucha resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
really a wild game where uh neither
player was uh you know satisfied with a
draw there there were some repetitions
but uh you know first alireza declined
the draw then Wesley declined the draw
and they just wanted to play they wanted
to keep the game going there were many
ways to keep the game going and all it
is just chose one
uh that was uh to uh too too difficult
to hold uh so here the point is after
King to G6 you're just gonna play Rook
day one kick away the knight from the
defense of the B1 square and that's it
there's no no way I wanted the Knight
moves you're gonna Queen the pawn and
that's it so basically uh you know a lot
has happened in this game but uh
basically one cell it is a
played this queen to D1 move and put
pressure on the A4 Pawn uh this is the
the moment the the game completely
shifted and it you know it was all
Wesley in the driver's seat from from
this point on even though it was it was
very scary uh he had to do a lot of King
walking but that's what you have to do
in order to beat uh former 2800 player
like alireza firusha uh so yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed the
first uh game that we're showing from
the super bet chess classic round one uh
we'll see what happens in the other ones
all the other games from round one were
drawn I'm gonna go uh through them and
see if you know some interesting
positions happen so we might show
another one but basically we are now
looking at round two or super bet chess
Classics so we'll see what happens and
what exciting games happen in in that
round uh so yeah uh uh uh thank you all
for watching I would like to thank
Wesley Carter Mark burzakaki a kid
tester Edmond Freeman and Evan Bursey
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continue the
coverage of the super bet chess classic
until the finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your Sunday